you you talk about you know all the
misinformation it's funny too because
this is the other thing i take away from
from jin saki's comment they're the ones
identifying misinformation well how many
times have they been wrong on that over
the last four years they they told us
the protesters were peaceful last summer
they told us that republicans defunded
the police they told us the dossier was
real they told us trump colluded with
russia
bob mueller did a 30 million
investigation said that's not accurate
i'm dave rubin and joining me today is a
congressman for ohio's fourth district
he serves as the ranking member of the
house judiciary committee and is a
co-founder of the house freedom caucus
congressman jim jordan welcome to the
reuben report it is good to be with you
dave and uh thank you for what you do
thank you for fighting for freedom and
and first amendment liberties for our
for everyone we i mean the country
appreciates that so uh good to be with
you oh well i appreciate the kind words
i uh can bounce that right back at you
you were one of the leaders especially i
think on the big tech stuff fighting for
free speech and free expression and
keeping the government and big tech out
of every little facet of our lives so
actually let's let's start right there
sure big tech well i'll give you the
broad question first and then we'll get
into the specifics yeah big tech what do
we do do you want to regulate do you
want to break them up do you believe
competition is enough is it all of those
is it none of those no it's it's it's
all of those and probably some more i
mean i i do think you got to get rid of
the liability protection the so-called
section 230 you got that that's a start
uh then i think you have to give and we
have we have a series of of
they'll be in bill form soon but but
ideas we're talking about give her to
230 private right of action like big
tech make some moderate content
moderation decision about you they got
to tell you why there needs to be some
training why they do that and frankly if
they do it and like desantis did in
florida if you're a candidate for office
and they do those kind of things there
should be a right of action you have to
hold them accountable so that's
something we're looking at and then
frankly i think you know justice thomas
has i think more than hinted that he
wants to address this issue
and talking about big tech and the power
they have so what we're also looking at
doing is speeding up the antitrust
actions in our court system so it gets
to the supreme court and we can get an
answer after all the trump
administration both the ftc brought uh
any trust action against facebook and
the justice department has brought in
any trust action against google and
we'll see how that all shakes out with
the biden doj but i think that's where
it has to focus versus what the
democrats are talking about doing which
is just giving more power to the ftc
which i think would translate into um
big government colluding with big tech
to further uh stick it to conservatives
right which is pretty much what's
happening already on on the 230 point uh
my audience is
all they all know about the difference
between platform and publisher and all
that the pushback on getting rid of 230
which i'm basically for getting rid of
it so i think we're pretty much lined up
there the pushback though is that if you
get rid of the protections that
basically all of these platforms twitter
youtube facebook etc that they will have
to censor more because they'll be
worried about the liability what would
you say to that
legitimate concern there's also the
concern that you know they're so big
they can handle the the the
the the lawsuits that come when they do
censor people and versus the competition
that we want to
have happen but i just think the
fundamental issue is look if they're if
they're making publishing decisions
editorial decisions they're not supposed
to have the liability protection and
that's we know that that's what they're
doing so i i think you just have to look
at sort of the fundamental questions say
okay you're making those editorial
decisions you don't get the protection
and then and then then then go from
there but that's why i think you also
need the other things i talked about um
to actually address this again what what
concerns me most is in an effort to deal
with censorship we have we have people
embracing this idea that oh we got to
give the government the the bureaucracy
the agencies more regulatory power and i
just think that's a mess and frankly we
just saw this we just saw this with jin
saki the spokesperson for the president
of the united states i mean think about
what she said she said big tech um are
now where so many people get their news
i.e they're the press and so she said we
are working with the press to stop
certain information from getting to we
the people the american people that is a
direct violation of their first
amendment freedom of the press the
liberties we have that's scary and they
got some list of 12 people who they said
are putting out misinformation so
there's that sort of fundamental
question i think that's what's what the
concern is is that marriage of big
government and big tech i think only
means conservatives get it worse
when you hear saki say something like
that her actual the word that to me was
the where the real bell went off was she
said we flag content for
facebook the implication is we're doing
it together right we're flagging it for
them
when you hear that do you ever go to
your democratic counterparts and go guys
look we may not agree on tax rates we
may not agree on abortion or blah blah
blah but i thought we at least agreed on
first amendment stuff do they do they
take that meeting do they take that call
they used to i don't know if they would
now and frankly my i have my i'm
skeptical they would now because it has
gotten so
so partisan and we've had a number of
democrats some of them on on the
judiciary committee the committee that's
supposed to safeguard the bill of rights
the constitution and americans
fundamental rights and liberties we've
had so many of them cheer on big tech
when they sense are conservative so it's
not the same it used to be
that you could work with i mean i always
make this this uh tell this story dennis
kucinich former member is a friend of
mine i mean i talked to him on the phone
a few months i just texted him yesterday
because i saw him on a clip on tucker uh
dennis is an old-school liberal who says
let's let's make the best arguments to
have the debate and he was with us on
civil liberties but that's not where
today's left is today's left is
authoritarian and you're seeing it from
the spokesperson of the president of the
united states estates in the white house
uh briefing room so it's a different
animal today and again i think that's
why you're so concerned and i'm so
concerned so many americans are about
what's really happening to our freedoms
yeah you know dennis kucinich is
actually a perfect example when he ran
for president which was you know
probably 16 years ago something like
that he was the furthest left democrat
at that point and basically the only
people who will talk to him now are
tucker and fox news they would never put
well
at this point and he was a champion of
civil we we were on the oversight
committee together when democrats had uh
power back when demo uh when when when
dennis was in congress he chaired this
subcommittee i was the ranking men and
when it flipped i was chairman he was
ranking member and there were issues
where we could work together typically
they were civil like we were both
concerned about facial recognition
technology and how law enforcement might
use that to violate our so we could work
together and when we didn't agree he was
a true liberal like let's have the
debate let's have get your best hold
make your best argument let's see who
wins after it's over we'll shake hands
and we'll get ready for the next issue
and have the debate that is so different
from what we see today where it's it's
so the the vitriol and going after
people and the canceling and everything
else it is a completely different animal
i long for the
for the people like kucinich like dennis
kucinich who's a good man and and
believes in so many the same things we
do when it comes to civil liberties
different on policy we're we're miles
apart on other policy issues but um
you know we need more of that frankly in
the united states congress i think i've
asked this question to every congressman
or senator that i've had on and i'd love
to know your take too do you know when
do you have a moment or was there a
person that you can point to when the
democrats really went off the deep end
with this stuff when it was okay no more
talking no more negotiating you guys are
all bad guys nazis whatever nonsense
they're throwing at you do you remember
when it happened well
i mean
i would probably point to november 8
2016 when donald trump got elected
president because we know what president
trump
like an individual by the way who i
think was did an amazing job as
president did more what he said than any
any president certainly in my lifetime
uh accomplished so much with relentless
uh attacks from the left and the and the
democrats and the media and frankly too
many republicans and still got so much
done um but i think it probably started
then now there may be something else but
the first thing that popped to mind was
the day he wins election democrats have
been
you know going after him and continue to
do so now five years later
yeah and then of course there's that
moment when rasheeda to leave the night
she got sworn in saying she was going to
impeach the guy years ago years ago
yeah and you have to have a crime before
the guilt right if i'm not mistaken i'm
a simple guy yeah but then we also learn
i mean you you think about it that we
learned that the fbi was spying on a
presidential campaign like that's not
supposed to happen in our great country
a major parties political or
presidential candidate their campaign
was being spied on by the other parties
justice department i.e the fbi jim comey
i mean
that's scary and and joe you you talk
about you know all the misinformation
it's funny too because this is the other
thing i take away from from jin saki's
comment they're the ones identifying
misinformation well how many times have
they been wrong on that over the last
four years they they told us the
protesters were peaceful last summer
they told us that republicans defunded
the police they told us the dossier was
real they told us trump colluded with
russia
bob mueller did a 30 million
investigation said that's not accurate
they told us trump cleared lafayette
square uh for a photo op the inspector
general said that's not true they told
us how about this one hunter biden was
russian misinformation holy cow we had
an eyewitness tony bobolinsky we had
actual documents the emails we had a
laptop and we had the fbi investigating
it but somehow was russia misinformation
i mean time and time again every major
story they told us was misinformation
they lied to us about it and now they're
the ones telling facebook oh you got to
take down this information that's
frightening if i could add a couple to
your list brett kavanaugh is a rapist
the covington kids jesse smallett i mean
the list the list goes on and on so as
you are seeing
sake say okay we're flagging things for
facebook or her other one last week
which was even worse in a way which was
if you're banned from one social media
site you should be banned from all as if
that has anything to do with her with
what her job is um
i i mean are you shocked like i think i
i'm not shocked right like i've been
doing this for a while i've been sensing
and learning about this stuff but i
think a certain amount of people are
like you know that voted for biden
because they had whatever their aversion
was to trump in the tweets or whatever
but i think a certain amount of people
actually are shocked right now like how
out of control this thing feels yeah i
think you're right dave you're not
because you follow and you know all
these these issues so well um
and frankly most of us in elective
office who've been here uh uh you know
for a few years we shouldn't be shocked
either because we we saw the trend we
saw the irs target conservatives we saw
what the fbi did to with the dossier
with the trump campaign and we saw what
they did with so we've seen all this
sort of progress so it it it's still
frightening it's still scary but we sort
of kind of saw some of this coming um
but i do think there are lots of
americans who are very nervous about
what they see happening to liberty i
talked with them and i was back in our
district last week talking with with
supporters and people they they're very
nervous about what they see
and how many times have you gotten the
line from someone who follows you you
see them at the airport or something
they come up to you and they'll say
i'm really nervous about our country can
our country because they love this
country they love the flag they love
what our country stands for they love
the people who sacrifice for our country
and and and liberated the country and
took on the nazis and everything they
love all that appropriately so but they
are nervous very nervous very concerned
about where the left wants to take us
and um that never used to that didn't
happen 15 years ago in politics but now
you you i get that every every time i'm
traveling to an airport right there used
to be a basic agreement that america was
fundamentally good and then it's like
okay we can argue from a liberal
perspective or a conservative now now
it's in essence should this thing
continue but backing up to the big tech
stuff for a little bit yeah so so
breaking them up let's talk about that
for a little bit what does that actually
look like like you want amazon basically
to have their server farm you know aws
as a separate company than say the
consumer facing side that we all you
know buy our toilet paper on or that
sort of yeah
what i think should happen is we have
historically done this we got a hundred
years of antitrust law we have
historically done this through the court
process now that is a slow process i
would like to speed that up because i
see the danger of big tech and i see you
know what we just talked about with with
the government pressuring big tech to do
certain things that the government
defines as misinformation that's that's
dangerous so i want that process speeded
up but what i don't want and what makes
me nervous is because i think it would
be a worse situation is to instead of
having it go through the court system is
to move it over to the regulatory
commission because right now at the ftc
the people who run the ftc are radical
leftists becca schlatter is a member on
the fct ftc commission she has said we
should use antitrust law to deal with
systemic racism yeah yeah you and i
would say no we shouldn't and a hundred
years of of any trust law says no we
shouldn't so that scares me lena khan
who's the new chairman of the ftc who by
the way when biden nominated and put up
for nomination from the senate didn't
tell the senators which is historically
the way it's supposed to work but he
didn't tell the senators that he was
going to make her chairman guess where
she worked before she went to the ftc as
chairman she for facebook or something
right well she worked there but more
importantly and more recently she worked
for jerry nadler david cicilline hakeem
jeffries all the people who were the
impeachment managers who put together
these bills my guess is lena khan wrote
the bills that give all the power to the
agency she now chairs
i don't think that's a good thing for
dave rubin who believes in the first
amendment and and jim jordan and the
folks i get to represent so that's my
concern let's let it work through the
court process
but let's do it quicker because as bad
as it's getting and the and the pace
that big tech is going to limit our
freedoms i want i want an answer soon
and i think justice thomas is with us my
guess is the courts with us because they
got to be
coney amy coney barrett justice alito
they got to be concerned with what they
see when the press secretary for the
united states president steps up at the
white house briefing room and says we're
working with facebook to take down
people's posts and take down information
so you basically see the judicial branch
i mean in essence the supreme court
because that's where this probably ends
up you you see that as the last firewall
right i mean at that point if nothing
else works and to your point if you're
if the whole uh
middle branch of government you know if
the if the congressional branch and all
the regulatory people if they're all
compromised it's judicial or nothing
well but we could do something
legislatively but frankly we're not in
control i mean right now the democrats
have the house they have the senate they
have the white house and they're going
to have the white house until president
trump runs and wins in 2024 which i hope
is what's going to happen i think he's
going to have to bowl so you think he's
doing it you think he's doing it i i i
do and i i've encouraged him to i've i'm
i mean i've every time i talk to him i
encourage him to run um but the the the
the truth is we can't change anything
right now so all we can do is what you
do we can highlight every time they're
infringing on americans liberties and i
do it every speech i give i all across
our district all across the country
every time i'm out talking i talk about
i just go to the first amendment i said
think about the first amendment the
liberties you have under the first
amendment every single one of them has
been assaulted by government over the
past several years i mean you your your
right to practice your faith your right
to assemble your right to petition your
government freedom to press freedom of
speech every single one i use the
example um
when i uh when they're they're still
churches today dave that that probably
well my guess is in l.a county they're
probably still churches today that a
full congregation can't meet on sunday
morning and and a few week this is
probably now what eight nine ten weeks
ago i spoke to think about your right to
assemble i spoke to the new mexico
republican party
in amarillo texas because they had to go
to texas to get freedom they had to go
to texas to be able to assemble in the
size they wanted to assemble because
their democrat governor wouldn't let him
assemble more than 149 people in the
state of mecca in new mexico so
that's crazy but and on and on it goes
so i think i think this is this is the
fundamental issue and and
i mean scares me to death scares me to
death so to that point how concerned are
you that just nobody trusts the system
anymore that that's sort of where i'm
getting which is you know that's what
the kids call black pill that you just
think that the thing is so broken that
nothing could be done and i always try
to put a positive spin on all this stuff
and i want to do solutions of course
that's that's why i do this but i think
a lot of people are just like you know
what i don't trust the medical experts
because of lockdowns and masks anymore i
don't trust the politicians who say one
thing about elections when their guys in
and the other the other way like that
that the whole system it only works if
we trust it and a lot of people just
don't trust it anymore
yeah and i'm very concerned about that
and it's um when you have
and again i think most of the blame
frankly lies with what with the left the
left as is is has attacked every
institution we have and frankly let's
just be honest the left controls almost
everything right the left controls big
media the left controls big tech the
left controls uh hollywood the left
controls higher education the left
controls big corporations the left now
controls big sports i mean just watch
the nba right i don't watch the nba
anymore right but the the left controls
the congress right now the left controls
the white house the one area they don't
control and this is this is the beauty
of our great country the one thing they
don't control is they still don't
control individuals we the people still
have individual liberties individual
rights so we can think for ourselves and
express ourselves and speak out but
they're even trying to stop that with
the whole cancel culture so and and
finally maybe the one institution that
they still don't control
is state and local government and that's
why what what uh desantis is doing in in
florida with the florida legislature
what they're doing they're pushing back
in our federal system that's how the
founders and god bless these individuals
put our system together there are not
only checks and balances with the
separate equal branches of government
there's the federalist system where the
checks and balances also come from the
states and that's where we have to fight
back now and we're having some governors
who are doing it and i think that's
giving
some more courage to other governors
particularly other republican governors
to step up and act like desantis is
doing in florida and push back on the
crazy left and and the policies they
want you mentioned they control the
media too how much of your day-to-day is
just uh pushing back on just the crazy
stuff that the media says
about not only you but just republicans
in general you know obviously a bunch of
racist homophobes and all that nonsense
and you know this will shift us to
another topic but you know you're
passing bills you guys are always
passing bills to restrict voting and
then you look at the actual bill not
that the not that the media ever does it
and you're like oh well it causes you
know voter id that seems okay and you
know uh paper trail that seems okay
making sure we count correctly that
seems okay but how much of your day is
just dealing with that sort of nonsense
a fair amount i mean
you know but i tell my colleagues i tell
guys in the freedom caucus and and
colleagues on the judiciary committee i
tell them look if if the press isn't
saying something bad at the mainstream
press if the press isn't saying
something bad about you you're not doing
anything any good so just under because
some people come here and they think
like oh they're not used to
um
just the relentless attack you're gonna
get if you're making a difference so um
it's it's a shock for some people but my
attitude is you have to embrace it
because that's just the way it is and
it's not fun it's not pleasant and you
just push back by telling the truth i
always tell tell people i i i think we
make this job as uh being a member of
congress we make it way too complicated
what did you tell the voters you were
going to do when you ran
they elected you to do that go do it
make the argument make the case do it in
this as compelling and articulate way as
you can but go do that and if you do
that and the press calls you all kinds
of names and you're like you said you're
racist and we're about terrible and
you're evil and all
okay fine we got it it's not fun but
we've got to live with just keep
pressing on because you're doing what
you told the voters you're going to do
and what i find is when you go back home
voters appreciate it even if they
disagree with you every once in a while
they'll say i just like the fact that
you're fighting and you're doing what
you said i don't agree with all of it i
agree with most of it but keep fighting
and that's what we're supposed to do i
think as a member of congress so what do
you make of the republicans that i sort
of at this point you know i'm kind of
new to this side right so i i maybe have
fresh eyes on this but you know when i
see a guy like mitt romney or or someone
like liz cheney i i call them pet
republicans because they go on msnbc
they get pat on the head like they're
doing anything and then in essence
they're democrats now that's fine if
that's what they believe at this point
but but when you guys get behind closed
doors like are you do you say to them
hey is there any conservative principle
is there any piece of the republican
party that you guys are here to defend
or is it just so that they're nice to
you on cable news yeah i just i never
get that i never get why um
[Music]
some some people want to go be the the
republican who attacks all the other
republicans i mean every once in a while
you're going to have some squabbles i
get that that's just normal course of
business but there's some republicans
who want to go on tv and just attack
republicans and of course cnn will love
you for a day love you for a minute love
you for a second but as soon as you're
not doing that then they're going to
turn around and start attacking you and
i i never get like don't you see that
don't don't don't haven't you figured
they just didn't take a genius to figure
this out um but yet you have some people
who who think their job is to be the
darling of of cnn and attack republicans
i just never understood it yeah so all
right so one other thing on big tech and
then and then we'll move on to some of
the other stuff are you worried at all
this is sort of an extension of the
black pill question but just that this
stuff has become so big that no matter
what you do no matter what you do at
this point that do you think it's
possible the ship has just sailed and
the government cannot do anything look
i'm i'm concerned i'm nervous i mean
don't misunderstand i think i think
just you know obviously with with the
question you asked
you have that you share that same
concern but
i mean i always come back to like this
is america we're americans we get things
done we've solved problems we've tackled
all kinds of obstacles i mean
you know there's a there's a there's
some people who make the case that you
know it's just um this this tough rugged
attitude is in our dna you know you
think about the people who started this
place
over in europe they said you got to
practice your faith a certain way and
they said no we don't we'll get on the
ship we'll risk it all we'll go to this
place called america and we're going to
do it the way we think we need to do it
the way the good lord wants us to do it
and they did it and we've overcome
everything and become the greatest
country ever so i still feel like
there's a ton of people who think like
you and i do who think like the folks i
get to represent back in the fourth
district of ohio who are willing to say
no we're not going to let it happen
we're going to fight we're going to do
what it takes in the right way to to to
prevail in the end for freedom for
liberty for free speech um
so i i guess i'm optimistic and maybe
maybe it's just because i'm you know
like you i'm american and i
i love the way we we conquer things and
get things done well i always tell
people i'm a world weary optimist
because i'm an optimist i don't think i
could do this if i wasn't how could you
say what you think for a living if you
were an optimist but but i'm also a
realist so that that gives you a little
world weary but to that point though if
they're if there are enough of us or
let's say there's more of us than them
what do we do about some of this
election stuff because it seems to me i
played a clip on the show last week
which was a compilation of of democrats
in 2018 including kamala and klobuchar
you probably saw it oh yeah it's about
15 democrats talking about rigged
elections talking about voting machines
that don't work talking about hacking
all of the stuff that i'm pretty sure
you and i could get blown up here on
youtube right this very moment for
talking about if we talk about it now
right right because dave you've you
forgot only democrats are allowed to
object to election results we can't i
always i have to make it out of my mind
yeah we're not allowed to i mean uh you
think about the folks on this this uh
january 6 commission on the democrat
side benny thompson objected to the
election results in 2001 when president
bush won jamie raskin the lead
impeachment managers in impeachment
round two uh he objected to florida on
january 6 2017. uh jim mcgovern jim
mcgovern on the day we had this this
the second impeachment uh debate on the
floor on january 13th he brought up the
week before january 6 and he said
republicans objected to the will of
people last week when they tried to
overturn the will of people and they
objected so i got up to speak right
after that and i said well you know i
said that i i said the the fine
gentleman the chairman of the rules
committee from massachusetts mr mcgovern
said that we we tried to overturn the
will of people i said but guess who was
the first person to object on january 6
2017. guess it was the first person
it was the right fine gentleman from
massachusetts who objected to
alabama think about that dave alabama
president trump won by like 28 points he
so he can object to alabama but jim
jordan and republicans can't object to
pennsylvania where they
unconstitutionally change their election
law i mean think about this one fact
the election law and passed by the uh by
the legislature as the constitution
requires
in pennsylvania said election ends at
eight o'clock tuesday you know
of course election day is always on
tuesday and first tuesday after the
first monday in november it is eight
o'clock tuesday democrats sued in the
partisan state supreme court and the
partisan state supreme court controlled
by democrats says no we don't care what
what the legislature said we don't care
what the law says election day now ends
at five o'clock friday they just extend
the election for three days so i'm not
allowed to object to that but jim
mcgovern can object to alabama when
donald trump wins alabama by 28 points
you got to be kidding me so that that's
the part that it drives and it's my
guess is you spend a lot of your time
doing the same thing i do pointing out
the freaking double standard with these
people but you have to do it because if
not they'll get away with it more let's
not forget i think his name is josh
shapiro the secretary of state of
pennsylvania who announced two days
before the election that biden was going
to win pennsylvania before the election
yeah the guy counting the votes
announces two days before who's going to
win
maybe there's a problem with them do you
need to call me craig
maybe maybe you know but of course
democrats like all you guys are crazy
you're somehow we're the conspiracy
theorists for just like
just like raising a question about that
so so what do you guys do on messaging
then because i'm not kidding i went
through the nine bullet points in the
last texas bill you know on the election
that the hb3 that they were going crazy
over and it really it was things like id
it was uh paper trail it was having
cameras when you're counting and a
couple very very basic things there was
nothing about race in there there was
nothing right to stop anyone from voting
there were actually things like actually
extending benefits so employers could
give more time for people to vote yeah
and yet it's called racist it's repeated
in associated press and on nbc and
everything else like how do you beat
that narrative
you know i think well again you put out
the facts you do like like like you did
but i also think like i'm past that
point what else do you do besides that i
think i think americans get it so take
this take the the the the texas
democrats so first of all that america
sees texas democrats getting on a
private plane uh you know taking their
football and going home not doing their
job coming to you know this is this is
emblematic of what the democrats think
i'm going to not do my job and i'm going
to go to washington where i can say i'm
a victim i mean that is like so democrat
right so they come to washington they
spread covet around to everybody else
they found a plane with no mass they had
they probably had to show so i think
sometimes just the common sense of
americans like these people are crazy
and i am convinced six months into this
administration the worst six months
start to any administration in my
lifetime i'm convinced so many americans
are like
well maybe maybe
maybe i didn't bargain for this maybe
this is maybe i should have voted for
president trump you know some of these
people who for whatever you know reason
decided not to vote for president trump
who was such a great president
and they and they vote for biden i think
they're like buyer's remorse big time
they're like
filling up their gas tank whoa this is
costing a lot more price of eggs bread
milk lumber price of tvs price price of
an airline ticket price of a hotel
everything's up and and crime in the
streets and oh oh oh i know by the way
march was the highest month on record of
illegal crossings in at our southern
border until april and april was the
highest month until may and may was the
highest month until june that's what you
call a trend in a very bad direction so
i think all that they're like saying uh
this this is so i think that that's how
it gets through is like americans have
common sense and they're figuring it out
congressman just to be clear they're not
kids in cages anymore they're young
people in fun centers yeah exactly
i've been down
well since i can
since i can tell you're not holding back
today you just mentioned uh biden i mean
what what do you think is really going
on with biden uh he is not all there
that's my professional uh diagnosis well
you know look
you know it's it's in some ways
it's a it's a big concern because as
much as we talk about all the issues
we've talked about
in the end you know our adversaries see
the same thing that that we see and you
know you saw
oh this is probably
three months ago uh when our secretary
of state secretary blinken was in alaska
in anchorage meeting with his chinese
counterpart and you know we had our team
on one side of the table and they had
the chinese on the other side and the
treatment that
the chinese gave to
the secretary of state of the united
states of america i'm like
i mean it was it was embarrassing and
and then and frankly you didn't see
secretary blinken really push back it's
like if that happened well first of all
that would not happen in the trump
administration to mike pompeo but if it
did if they were crazy enough to say
those kind of things to pompeo i know i
know mike he'd got up like maybe he
flipped the table over or he he would
have got up or he would have said
with all due respect that is entirely
wrong you don't talk to i mean it would
have there would have been pushback real
pushback like you're supposed to do in
real diplomacy when you come from a
position of strength
and it didn't happen and i'm like
now we see china what they said to japan
just a couple days ago and now we see
what putin is saying about any type of
things we're going to put in europe i'm
like
that's what happens when you don't
project strength and when you have a
commander-in-chief you have a president
united states who is
behaving in the way president biden is
and it's in its dangerous for not only
the united states and our security but
frankly for our allies and and how
things work in the world and that's
that's troubling i think and yeah i mean
obviously you see it and i think so many
americans do do you hear that from
counterparts in other countries because
my belief although the media won't show
it this way my belief is that other most
certainly western european countries but
i think most of europe i think most of
south america i actually think most of
the world they want us to be strong they
they want us to lead of course
and of course they do now they might go
out because of the liberal press and and
after a world leader meets with
president trump my guess is behind the
scenes they're saying hey keep it up
keep saying you know they appreciate it
then they'll go out and they'll they'll
they'll do the liberal stuff and they'll
say bad things about president trump but
they appreciate it when america i always
say this the world's a safer and better
place when we lead and you can't lead
militarily and diplomatically unless you
lead economically and right now the
democrats are doing everything wrong
think about just think about economics
democrats lock down states democrats
spin like crazy democrats pay americans
not to work and then for those who are
working they're getting ready to raise
your taxes now that's for the dumbest
ideas i've ever heard but that's what
they're doing economically so that is
going to hurt our chance to lead both
diplomatically and militarily because
the way this world operates is you
better be the economic superpower if
you're going to be the military so they
work together and that's the part that
scares me so um
yeah
do you think it's too much of a jump to
say that in essence the democrats right
now are basically just doing china's
bidding i mean if you keep locking us
down keep wrecking our economy keep
making sure that we don't go to meetings
and put you know a strong posture out
there uh that we make it clear that
china can basically do whatever they
want that the chinese got to be pretty
happy plus there was some stuff on
hunter biden's laptop which i'm not sure
if we're allowed to talk about that
anymore that they might have on biden i
mean there's just it's just a whole mess
no it it is
uh i i don't i mean i don't want to
think it's that you know
that word that we got people in our
government doing things you know in that
way i i just think that
you know i i had kevin mccarthy in
studio a couple weeks ago and he said
for sure that eric swalwell has been
compromised by a chinese spy and he said
nancy pelosi knows it
okay he's the minority leader of the
house like is he lying to me
no but he gets briefings that i don't
get i mean i was on the intel committee
for a few months back during the the
first impeachment so i don't i don't get
the the briefings that that leader
mccarthy gets so i mean if that's what
kevin said i believe him 100 percent um
it's just
i just think that we got so many members
now in in you know members of congress
members of the people in the government
who who are who are willing to do what
the radical left says it's just like
they have taken over the democrat party
you said it earlier dave and i think
this is so true
we now have the the bulk of one of the
major political parties in our country
who thinks the country's bad i mean like
that
i mean i've tried my my background's in
the sport of wrestling i've been to cuba
twice i've been to the what was then the
soviet union and i tell people you go to
places like that
you think the good lord you live here i
was i was joking was i said i was in
moscow in february moscow in february
it's like 400 below zero man you thank
the good lord and the food was terrible
and cuba was a war
yeah and cuba was a warm soviet union
and i always tell folks it's not about
the people the cuban people were great
the great athletes that the the russian
people that but when you have a system
that doesn't doesn't value freedom and
and rule of law and private property
rights and
bad things happen so now we have a major
political party in the country where you
have a bunch of leftists who think our
country where we have all those things
private property rights rule of law
freedom liberty they think all that's
bad and they want to and they want to
put all their authoritarian baloney on
the rest of us that's the problem and
that's why we have to fight back in in a
the most compelling and articulate way
that we can
so speaking of authoritarian baloney you
said to me right before we started this
thing because you know i'm out here in
cali you said how long are you going to
stay out there i mean just in the last
you know week or so we suddenly have an
indoor mask mandate again it's done by
one middle management bureaucrat i have
no idea where the mayor is as you know
we're in the midst of the recall of the
governor uh thank the good lord but
do you think that any of the do you
think this stuff is going to stop at any
point or does the government now just
have
the idea of covid so that at any point
any authoritarian in any of these blue
states can just be like yeah we're
locking you down again yeah we're
putting masks on you again and god knows
what comes down the pipe yeah i i i
think democrats may try some of that
they may even try i mean speaker may try
it here they may put the mass mandate
back on members of congress you know
even though probably you know just about
every single member of congress has
probably already been vaccinated uh but
so but i i tend to i go back to the
optimistic point that we were talking
earlier i think americans have had it i
know the folks i represent the fourth
district of ohio west central north
central ohio they're like ain't no way
ain't no way
i'm going back to all that baloney
they're going to do that tomorrow
business our small business our company
and i'm going to there's no way mike
dewine is going to make me wear masks
and do all that it's just not going to i
just don't see it happening and i think
you're going to see state after state
and a lot of these governors saw that
when
governor desantis and some other
governors stood up
took a principled position and then it
played out and looked like you know
their economy was stronger they didn't
have any worse code in many cases they
had better code with numbers i think a
lot of these governors like you know
what desantis did it right um we're
going to do more of that so i think the
people this country are going to say
time out we're not going there again i
don't care what dr fauci says i don't
care what they say we're going to we're
smart people we're americans we believe
in liberty we understand covet is
serious we understand it's real but
we'll deal with it in the right way
we're not gonna shut down our business
we're not gonna wear mass we're not
gonna shut down our schools can you just
talk a little bit about what it was like
sort of more towards the beginning of
covid when when everything's breaking
nobody knows exactly what's going on two
weeks to flatten the curve i'm sure
you're there with the governor you're
there with some of the mayors you're
with other congress people you're trying
to figure out what to do
like
i guess it's different in every state
but you know is it the governor that's
usually deciding this stuff or are they
just handing it over to these middle
management people i mean we had you know
there's this famous woman here in l.a
sheila cool who voted yeah she was the
deciding vote three to two to close
outdoor dining and then what'd she do
right after she voted right now she goes
out to eat in santa monica yeah and it's
like those are the people we've really
had it with no one knew this woman
beforehand yeah no i i know that that
double standard pelosi going to the
salon when we couldn't gavin newsome
going to a five-star restaurant when he
told us we couldn't have thanksgiving
with our family i mean that's the kind
of stuff that excuse me um drives
americans uh crazy but yeah when it when
it first started there was i think some
concern but in many in our state i was
the governor working along with uh the
health director uh dr acton um and they
seem to be running everything and our
and god bless our general assembly in
the end they finally took a while but
they finally pushed back and they passed
legislation that said if the governor is
going to put in some emergency order
it's for a specified period of time
and then
the general assembly has to sign off on
it if it's going to go any further and
the governor vetoed it and they overrode
the governor's veto so that's what we
need more of in some of these states
where governors were um
doing things and not following the
constitution yeah if i'm not mistaken
newsome gave himself unlimited emergency
powers i mean he's he's palpatine from
star wars i don't know if i can make a
star wars reference with you i think i
can uh but that that in essence is what
he is uh all right let's let's talk
about a couple other things so you know
there's this january 6th commission
you know most of my audience i think is
probably where you are with this which
is that we've watched two years of riots
in the streets everywhere burning down
our cities and attacking federal
courthouses and all of that and we had
democrats literally bailing people out
and doing nothing and lawlessness
everywhere but they've got their thing
they've got their
insurrection and they want hearings and
they want to spy on more people now
because of it and censor more of us and
everything else
what what's your take on on no you're
the whole thing you're right this is
this is the this is impeachment round
three they they're obsessed with going
after president trump they're going to
do it again
there's a fundamental question that
needs to be answered but my guess is
democrats on the committee won't address
it and that is
why was there not a proper security
presence and posture that day because
that's the speaker's responsibility my
guess is they don't want to go there
there was all kinds of information they
knew there was going to be a big rally
it wasn't any secret president trump was
having a rally uh why not have the
proper security presence here for an
important day like january 6 where you
where you count and certify uh the the
electoral uh votes from each state so i
i don't know that they'll go there i
think this is driven by the fact that we
talked earlier what else they got to
talk about they got to talk about crime
going up in every major urban area
they're going to talk about the price of
everything going up on on every single
good and servers you can think of
they're going to talk about the the
border situation so they're going to
talk about they're getting ready to
raise taxes they're going to talk about
i mean they're going to talk about the
fact they're going to keep spending
spending spending driving a price even
higher i mean what else do they got to
talk about so they're going to do this
and they're going to attack the
president because that's all they got i
mean
what is it cnn's ratings now are down so
far because because
and yet they're still talking about
trump but they can't do it in the same
way they did before so they've been
obsessed with going after president
trump um
and here they go again because that's
the only thing they got in their
playbook congressman you forget that joe
biden tweeted out that the average
american saved 16 cents on their july
4th cookout that's pretty good that's
pretty good
16 wait you know you've mentioned the
second impeachment a couple times just
real quick on that did anyone think that
it was legit i mean even i know how you
felt about it but did any of the
democrats at that point there was no
support for it in the country except in
the most radical
quarters did anyone think it was legit
well the the hard lefties in the
congress sure just like the hard lefties
around the country but you're right the
rest of the country is like what are you
doing he's not he's gonna he's leaving
office in in in a few days and the trial
actually took place after he was out of
office so um
yeah but that's when you when it's an
obsession
i mean it it was it's truly an obsession
with these folks and i you know i
remember when i first heard the term
trump derangement center i'm like wow
you know whatever but you you've i'm
sure you've been around people who are
like no it's a it's a thing people just
get like consumed with being against
president trump and it's it's sometimes
it's tough in families you know we gotta
we got relatives who are like most of
them are most of them are not most of
them love president trump they're like
me they love what he did for the country
but others are like whoa and you're just
like oh we never saw that coming but
some people it just hits them and they
can't they can't shake it loose yeah so
on the trump front i mean you you
obviously were and are one of his big
allies um was there anything that you
tried to get him to soften on or change
on or message differently that he didn't
that you think might have hurt him
no i mean well
when when president trump first came
into office paul ryan put put forward
the obamacare repeal legislation
terrible terrible terrible approach and
i thought the wrong bill we should have
just done what we had passed back in the
end of 2016 what that what we campaigned
on we should have just passed that
that's what mitch mcconnell wanted to do
because he had the votes in the senate
to pass that we passed in the house
should have brought up the same bill
paul ryan decides no we're going to do
this three bucket approach we're going
to do part of it here then we're going
to do some of it through regulatory
reform i'm like what are you talking
about so i opposed the ryan um health
care repeal because it was bad it wasn't
what we told the voters were going to do
and president trump was new to office he
was actually he actually supported what
what paul was doing and then once that
went through then mark meadows went to
work and we got another bill to pass
past the house that was much more
consistent with what we told the voters
were going to do and unfortunately we
all remember when john mccain gave the
thumbs down and didn't pass but i think
that's through that process where we
were actually opposed to what what the
speaker was doing and what the white
house was supporting i think president
trump learned like oh you can count on
these guys they're going to stick with
stuff and then mark and i just became we
just got to know the president and we so
appreciated his
doing what he said he would do i mean
that's what the freedom caucus is our
mission statement we talk about doing
what we told the voters were going to do
that's what president trump did and we
went to bat for him because he did it i
mean you just think about this
every single presidential candidate both
republican and democrat over the last
several cycles for for most of my
lifetime have said if you elect me
i will put the embassy in jerusalem
they've all said it they get elected and
then they come up with a bazillion
reasons why they can't do what they said
they were going to do and frankly what
they were elected to do president trump
gets elected he goes i'm going to do it
all the state department people said
well mr president you better not do that
any other concerns he goes i told the
people i want to do it i'm going to do
it he did it and it worked out fine so
that that is what i so appreciated about
this guy and we need a lot more frankly
like him willing to do what they said in
elective office yeah so you've mentioned
desantis a couple times i mean obviously
you like him one of the things that i've
been saying is look if desantis runs to
me we need some young blood i think he's
only 40 42 or 43 i mean it would be a
generational shift and that maybe trump
acts as the bodyguard he still takes all
the hits he deals with all the media
nonsense but then it allows for just a
change because we act we need a change
if nothing else then just for age and
just that we need to move forward or so
you know that sort of sounds uh it
almost sounds pie in the sky but we just
need we just need some new blood
uh but you it sounds like you want trump
either way even though you like desantis
oh yeah i want president trump i i think
first of all i i think again as i said a
few times
no one was no one has proven that they
can take as much heat and as much
intensity as president trump took and
still get so much done still do so much
of what he said so i definitely am for
president trump i want him to run that's
who i'm for if he chooses not to you're
right ron desantis
would be great ron there was nine of us
who started the freedom caucus ron was
one of nine ron has been rock solid and
what he's done in florida is sticking to
his guns and plus i always tell folks it
doesn't it never hurts to be smart ron
desantis is a smart guy he's a smart guy
it never hurts to have smart people and
if you got smart people who are
principled who are in positions of
leadership even better so i think that's
who president trump is i think that's
who ron desantis is but i want president
trump to run i am a hundred percent for
him i think he's our best candidate but
if he doesn't ron desantis would be
great yeah what else has been on your
mind i'm going to give you a general one
here like just what else is sort of
running through your mind as you're
doing your job these days and all the
craziness
uh fauci knew on january 31st
2020
at 10 32 p.m he gets an email from dr
christian anderson one of his
virologists who's who had received our
tax dollar your tax money my
constituents tax money received our tax
dollars doing research he sends an email
to dr fauci 10 32 january 31st 2020 and
he says the virus looks engineered it's
not consistent with evolutionary theory
so anthony fauci's on notice clear back
at the at the early in the first month
of 2020 that this virus came from the
lab most likely looks engineered not
consistent with evolutionary theory
didn't jump from an animal to a human
he's unnoticed and what does he do over
the next year down plays that tells us
something different and so to me that
that is like you're the highest-paid
official in our government you're the
you're on every talk show you're covered
every day you're time magazine person of
the you know the
the greatest person on the planet for
the last thousand years or whatever they
gave him and and like and you're
misleading the american people and
there's things that happen after that
emails that happened that that that
reinforced that i think he knew early on
by by february first the next day i
think he knew there's a lethal virus on
the loose there's been gain of function
research funded at the wuhan institute
of virology that gain of function
research did and go through the p3
framework the oversight framework and i
got an email from one of the virologists
who's an expert in this area who says
the virus looks engineered not
consistent with evolutionary theory he
knew all that on february 1st
do you think he's do you think he's
actually in trouble for lying to
congress i mean that's what rand paul
was really trying to get him on in the
last couple days in effect saying hey
you said that that art the nih funding
did not have anything to do with this
virus being engineered in the wuhan lab
and now it kind of looks like it is he
was his answer was very confusing
because he basically was sort of saying
well we funded some stuff not
necessarily that study and right you
know he gave a lot of bureaucratic uh
double speak and a subgrant through
ecohealth blah blah blah it's like it
was american tax dollars going through
equal health going to the to the to the
wouton wuhan institute of porology so
look at the email he sent he gets that
1032 email from dr christian anderson
saying looks engineered not consistent
with evolutionary theory two hours later
12 38 in the morning he sends an email
to his top assistant dr austin claus
who's worked for him for like 16 years
he sends an email and says hugh keep
your phone on important task you will
have to do read this paper that i've
attached
it was like you know the household on
fire kind of email and that atta the the
paper he attached
was an article written by dr she the
so-called bat woman in in
wuhan china where they're talking about
gain of function research so dr austin
kloss 11 hours later gets back to dr
fauci 11 47 a a uh a.m the next morning
uh february first gets back and says
gain a function research was happened it
didn't go through the p3 framework i
will look to see if we have any ties to
it in other words i'll look to see if if
what we need to do to cover our backside
that that to me tells a lot and now
again
maybe i'm misinterpreting i'm just
reading the emails maybe i'm wrong about
the emails but dr palchi he doesn't want
to come testify in front of us anymore
the select committee on the coronavirus
democrats won't invite him in we invited
him in republicans wouldn't come he goes
to every tv show testifies testified i
think like 18 times in front of congress
but won't come in front of us again i'd
love to question him one more time right
and then of course there's that email
from i think it was february or march
where he just has a friend emailing him
about you know she's going on vacation
and does she have to wear masks and he
basically says well if you buy the mask
at a store it doesn't work anyway yeah i
mean the misinformation i mean think
about that they're they're going after
us for mr or other people for
misinformation but the misinformation
we've received from the government and
from the from the mainstream press on so
many issues as you pointed out earlier
um
it's just ridiculous
yeah all right on that on that note and
that was a professional cough you did
right there you didn't you didn't do it
in the hand you went this way um
on that note if if people want to pay
attention to the big tech stuff that
you're working on uh where can we send
them because i think people are just
like hey i want to help somehow it
doesn't even mean with dollars i just
want to know what's going on and what
bills i should support and that sort of
thing yeah
go to the judiciary committee website um
uh we will have information up there we
have the principles up there we're
trying to put them in bill form we want
to we want to get there soon um but go
to the judiciary website i don't know i
mean our our immediate people and our
staff know that what that is but uh
there's a lot of dots
they don't look that good frankly that
would be you want to do your major job
you get them to rehash redo all of those
government websites
yeah
uh congressman i appreciate i appreciate
your time i've had a good time thanks
keep up the good fight we need we need
to fix some of this stuff you you you
keep it up and we need we need defenders
like like you out there talking about
protecting
americans liberties and specifically the
first amendment so god bless you
i got nothing better to do than save the
world thanks man thank you if you're
looking for more honest and thoughtful
conversations about politics instead of
non-stop yelling check out our politics
playlist and if you want to watch full
interviews on a variety of topics watch
our full episode playlist all right over
here and to get notified of all future
videos be sure to subscribe and click
the notification bell